okay just one okay
yeah so today i will briefly talk about
where you can find
all the physics tools and mostly i will
be talking about set replace
and i will briefly explain what local
systems are
and i think in the next talk sean and
we'll talk about multiverse system
and maybe other resource functions
so okay
so i will be talking about four main
things today
so first is again as i just said
where you can find this different
functions and
in particular i will tell you how to use
set replace functions like wolfram mods
and go from all plot directly without
uh resource functions and then
i will tell you about how set replays
work internally a little bit and it's uh
somewhat different ways to look it's a
somewhat different way to look at both
the model than you would then what
you're familiar with
and then i will talk a bit about various
features
of wall from modern one for model plot
and where you can find documentation and
then finally
i will tell you about the new feature
which was just released yesterday
which are local multi-resistance
okay so so first of all
there are two ways you can find wall
from physics functions
the first one is wall from function
repository
and there is this page you can get to
from the wall from physics website by
clicking on tools
and it lists all of almost
all resource functions we have except
maybe some
very recent ones and
there are a lot of good stuff here so i
encourage you to
take a look at these functions and it's
it's it's usually better to use an
existing function rather than
implementing something itself
so take a look and all these functions
do and
one thing to keep in mind that these
functions are not quite as polished as
for example built-in
functions in the wolfram language so for
example they would genuinely not tell
you if you
use incorrect arguments and so on so
just be vigilant when you're using them
and use common sense that you know the
outputs make sense
okay and there are warfare modern
warfare model plot here as well
and this resource functions are just
wrappers
around set replace and in fact it is
in my opinion it's much easier to use
them from a certain place directly and i
will
tell you how to do that so just some
examples of functions
you can find there are things like
multi-base system which
eisen johnson will talk more about in
the
next tool stock and then you can for
example generate a random wall for model
rule
you can enumerate wall for models and
then one cool thing which i don't think
is in this list yet is quantum to
multiway system which is a function
journal made recently which allows you
to take a
operator and a quantum operator and the
basis
and then make a multi-way system based
on strings which
emulates that system so
i encourage you to check it out as well
and then
set replace so the three main functions
it has a wall from model
wall from one evolution object which is
what lawful model produces as an output
and then go for model plot which allows
you to plot
both model states and there are some
other helper functions
and utility functions uh you can
find in the documentation and then the
code for set replace
lives in this github repository
which if you are going to be working on
features of the evolution
for example you might want to work on
this code and modify it and so on
certainly pull requests
and if you want to do it tell me so that
i can add you to this repository
but one thing i want to point out that
it has a very large readme
there's loads of examples and explaining
what different properties are and what
which options you can supply to every
function so
if you're working with some features of
wafer model i recommend you to
take a look at this
okay so now you can use set replace
functions through
function repository and it generally
works fine
but there are limitations so for example
it
doesn't work very well without internet
connections between restarts
of the kernel and then it's a bit slower
and then you don't get syntax of the
completion with it
so what i encourage you to do uh
and especially if you have a slides open
encourages it right now is to evaluate
this pocket install command
which will install the most recent
booklet
and in in the future you can generally
just say
pocket install set replace which you
download is from wall from sparkly
server
but it doesn't quite do it yet because
this new version that was released
yesterday
is not there yet so but you can still
install it directly from the github
releases page
and in the future if you
open this releases page you know every
time there are significant
changes it would make a new release and
you can see what's new
so you can keep following it even after
the summer school
okay and then after you installed it you
just
do get set replace which is
less and less less less and less less
yeah it's in syntactic sugar for the get
command
and then backtick at the end and then
you can just use all these functions
like
if there are system functions so for
example you can
you know do to all the normal stuff and
one cool feature you get with this is
syntax auto completion so for example
once you want to specify property
in wafer model now you get this list of
all available properties and especially
if you're not very familiar with the
code
it makes it much easier to use it
and then if you want to modify the code
and set replace
it's fairly easy to do as well and what
you'll need to do is to clone the
repository
and then go to the set replace directory
and there are build script and install
script so you call the build skill first
and if you're on linux it will probably
work right away so you need to have wall
from script installed but if you do
it would probably work right away on
linux on the mac you will need xcode
or common line tools and on windows you
will have to install a compiler and it's
a bit more complicated there but if you
need any help with compiling it
just you know select me and they will
help you to do it
okay so let me then
explain how set replace works
so set replace works with
a slight generalization of wolfer model
which are said substitution systems
and basically it's
it's just a system that substitute
subset from a set with another subset
so and we start with a set of
expressions
and set it just it's assumed it's an
ordered so just another collection of
expressions
and then there is a rule which says take
some number of expressions from this set
and replace it with another subset and
in fact since version 12.1
there is a build function that can do it
so it's called subset replace
and you can just take a list or set of
expressions
and you can apply rule to them and you
see it replaces 1 2 with a 3
and then 5 and 6 is 11 and this 3 is
left
by itself and you can do exactly the
same thing with wafer model
but just when you specify the rules you
need to say pattern rules and put it in
an association
and then that's the rule which is
similar to the rule here
and then the initial state uh goes here
and then to get the actual
expressions set of expressions as a
result
you request a property called the final
state and you get exactly the same
result
so you might wonder why would you even
want to use wafer model if you already
have subset replace
so the reason is that wolfer model has a
lot of functionality to make it easier
to analyze the systems
in particular if you just call it
without any property
it gives you this wall formal evolution
object
and then you can ask a lot of things
from it not just the final state
for example there is a property called
expressions events graph
which should give you this visualization
of what the system actually does and
here you can see
we have one two isn't inputs and
yeah so the light blue vertices
correspond expressions the elements of
the set
and then the orange vertices correspond
to events so here for example there are
two events
and they take one two and give you three
and then five six and give eleven and
this three is never used
so it's you know it's useful to see
what's happening in the system
so now what does it have to do with
welfare models so
in the wolfram model expressions are
ordered lists of atoms and atoms are
just
some you know any senator they don't
have internal structure they're just
labels
and atoms are hyperion of vertices
and expressions are hypergraph edges or
hyperedges
and the each expression of hyperedge is
ordered
within itself and the entire thing is
unordered
again and in order to make a wolfram
model rule
you do it in this way so on the left
hand side
we now have two triplets of atoms or two
ternary edges
and then this v2 is shared
between them which means it has to
appear in both of those edges
at this particular positions and then on
the right
we have a module and what module does is
that it creates a new
uh name for this variable v6
and then it puts this in an edge in the
edges
on the right hand side and to
demonstrate it
more clearly we could just run model by
itself
and so you can see if you don't assign
anything to v6 it just escapes
and you get this random name
as an output and this is kind of
what wolfer model will do in this case
so you can
use this row as a pattern rule and you
just get the evolution of evolving model
as you would normally but it it's kind
of inconvenient to keep writing modules
and patterns all the time everywhere so
there is a just syntactic sugar to
simplify it
and what you do is just you drop
patterns on the left
and you drop the module on the right and
it knows which vertex is new because it
doesn't appear on the left it only
appears on the right
and then you get this simplified
notation for it
and you can even drop the v's and just
leave the numbers
in which case all you get is just a
normal way of specifying both models
and you can always go back to these full
pattern specification by using two
pattern rules function
it should give exactly the same things
here
okay so throughout this talk
i will be using this uh
vocabulary which is slightly different
from a normal one but i think it's it's
easier to use it because for example if
you're talking about expression events
graph
there are edges in this graph between
expressions and events
which are not hyper edges so if you use
the word age there
then it's not clear whether you're
talking about edges in that graph
or the hyper edges and it gets confusing
so
essentially the expression is an element
in this unordered set
or in other words a hyper edge then the
atom is a part of that
expression or vertex and then
the set is the state of the system of
the hyper graph and then
the rule well you know what the rule is
and then
there are events and matches the
difference between them is that event
is an application of the rules that was
instantiated
whereas a match is an application of a
rule that is possible
but it has not been instantiated either
not yet
or because there is an event selection
function that
prevents it from happening
okay so now another thing
i want to explain is is how set replace
handles these evolutions internally
so kind of the ordinary way of thinking
about
waffle models is in terms of states so
for example you have this rule this
initial condition and you
evolve it for four steps and as a result
you get the state's plots list
with just a list of states and
these states well as you i'm sure you
know
they they don't just have one event in
between them
they have events applied everywhere in
non-operating ways
as in as many players possible
but actually internally set replace
doesn't work like this
in other words it's like you might think
that all it does is that it takes a
state
and then apply some events and get
another state and it just remembers
those states
but actually no what it does it it keeps
track of
all of the edges throughout the
evolution it has
all possible matches at every point and
then
it remembers all the events it applied
and in fact if you look at the internal
structure of the wolfram evolution
object which i would
talk in more detail but later
you can see that there are no states in
here they're just
atom lists which are just lists of
expressions a list of hyperedges
we just has all of them uh in a single
list
and then it just has a list of events uh
with inputs and outputs
and again as i mentioned previously
the it only has three things which it
remembers
and this list of all expressions
throughout the evolution
it it's not just catenated states it's
more saturdays because for example here
it starts with three binary self loops
which is the initial condition here but
as
but the next edges here are 2 2
2 1 one two and one two but there's no
one one here
because it's the same one one as this
one one it was just
never it was not used
going from the first state to the second
state so it got preserved and it's still
the same edge so it doesn't appear here
twice
and to demonstrate
how this works actually we can look at
the expressions events graph state by
state
so we start with three edges three
binary self loops and then we go step by
step so it first
finds two edges that match the rule
and it creates outputs and then it finds
another two edges
and it creates the outputs and by
default it does
it never he uses edges so once it's used
once it doesn't use it anymore so it
only looks at
uh expressions here with out degree
zero and it keeps
you know it can match expressions from
different layers as well and it just
keeps doing it and note that this
particular state here
is in between well this
configuration here is in between states
because
this is a complete previous state
because it's fixed number of layers
and it started evaluating the next layer
but it didn't finish it yet
so now it's in between the
well the force of see
between the second and the third step
okay so now let's talk about some
specific functions or features
in set replace so first of all as i
mentioned previously there is this
readme
and in particular has navigation bars at
the top
so what you can do is you go to symbols
and functions for example
and then you can go to wolfram model
and then to properties and here are all
the properties for example you can ask
from the evolution object like causal
graphs and then you see some examples of
cosmographs
and i will go through some of those
parts of the readme
right now and i will not i mean i
definitely won't have time to go through
all of them so
i encourage you to look at it later
okay so one of the functions we have
there
is welfare model plot which is
what we use to plot the wall from one
states and
by default it draws each hyperedge or
each expression
as a convex polygon around the
corresponding
viruses atoms so here for example
there's three expressions here one two
three three four five and five six
seven one and i also included your text
labels
to make it easy to see what's going on
so it get there are some
edge cases here so for example if you
have self loops
it still does a similar thing that it
draws a convex polygon around this edge
but since
the atoms in it or your scenario used
it just draws a self loop so for example
the reason this one one one
has two self loops it's because it
first treats it as two pairs of one so
it's one
one here and one one here and
each of them correspond to one self loop
and then it draws a convex polygon
around the whole thing
so that's how you can see it's a ternary
hyperedge and not two binary hyperedges
and then three four four is a similar
thing so there is a c4 and that is a 4 4
and then there is a convex polygon
around the entire thing
and for example if you have to
distinguish between
something like one to one and two edges
two three and three two
you can check whether it's filled inside
one to one or not
and then it's if you have overlapping
edges and so on sometimes it can get
pretty complicated but you can still
kind of see what's going on because
for example here the shade of blue is
slightly darker and there are
double edges here which is how you can
see there are two
jordana edges turning high pressure
three four five
here and so on then if you have
urinary hyperedges they are
thrown circles around corresponding
atoms is the number of vertices
corresponding to
the number of circles corresponding to
how many unitary
hyperedges you have there and then you
can understand
that for example you can highlight
certain parts of the hypergraph
like hyper edges and vertices and so on
which is
especially useful if you're writing
documents
and then if you don't like the cyclic
nature of the polygons
because it it connects the last project
to the first vortex
and you might not want to do it because
there is
i mean it does it to show you where
individual hyper radius are but if you
don't want to do it you can disable it
by setting hyperage rendering to sub
graphs
in which case it would draw all of the
hyperedges as just sequence
of viruses so if you're doing something
like a subway map for example you
wouldn't
want them to be polygons so you could
just color them in different colors
instead
and this option h style even supports
patterns
so for example you can
say that every binary hyperage should be
dark green
but every eternal rehydration will be
dark red
and this is what you would get
okay so another visualization function
is
root plot and
the reason you would want to use root
plot instead of a mole plot
for rules is that it shows you
identical elements in the rule
at the same places so for example it has
one two one two on both sides
well it has one and two on both sides
so it puts them in the same place
and it also does it with whole hyper
edges
and it also highlights some different
shades of blue so you can see which ones
are shared
and it supports multiple rules as well
by
showing them side by side and so on
okay so now let's go to walford model
so wolfer model
generates evolution objects by default
as
i explained previously so the way you
use it as you specify rule first
then initial condition and then the step
specification
which i'm going to talk about more next
slide
and in this case we just ask it to
generate eight events
and then we get this profile model
evolution object so
the way it works is that so
guys it has some internal structure and
it
has this little labels which can kind of
let you see what's going on
so in particular it says generations
four triple dot five
so what it means is there are four
complete generations
which means that once you get to the
four
generations which are one two three four
there are no more edges
no more hype ranges that would appear on
the
fourth generation meaning that it's
complete
all of the new copyrighted expressions
will go to the fifth generation and
beyond
and then this five is a total number of
generations
meaning that what is the deepest one
that it goes to
and generations just correspond to
layers in this
expression events graph for alternative
causal graph
so each time a new event is created
its generation is one more than the
highest generation of
its inputs so like this edge for example
see this expression regeneration one
this one has generation two and
therefore this event and
all of its outputs have generation three
and so on
so then you can as i
short previously you can look at the
internal structure of the evolution
object
uh and it only has a first part doesn't
have any other parts in it
and this is all that's used to evaluate
properties so for exa so specifically it
tells you first that's it's
a version 2 data format which is
the new version which was introduced in
the release yesterday
and then it repeats what the rules are
which it also shows
here and then
again the maximum complete generation
termination reason which
just tells you which of these
step limiters was triggered and i will
talk about it more later
and then atom list is the same thing as
all expressions throughout
evolution and then etc
some properties of events are including
generations
and then to get things from the
evolution
object what you do is you call different
properties from it
and some properties also have options so
for example for expressions events graph
you can
specify vertex labels lost automatic and
you can include the initial event which
is this event
here and it's just an event that takes
no inputs and creates initial condition
and now for the many different
properties like all events count
and there is even property called
properties which gives you a list of
all available properties and
as a zinc target sugar you can also
specify
properties directly in golfer model as a
force argument so for example
when it's all events edges list or
count which will tell you the total
number of
edges or expressions throughout the
evolution
okay now let's talk about
step limiters so these are the things
you can specify the third argument
involving model which tells you
which tells it how long it should be run
in the evolution
so the number here means a number of
generations
so for example here we ask it for four
generations which is
what it does and
one thing to know about this number of
generations
is that it would not terminate
the first time it have encountered the
higher generation
rather it would just ignore the matches
which have generation that is too high
and it would apply all the other matches
as long as possible
and in the default evolution also it
doesn't matter
because it would always produce event
generation by generation
but if you use custom event ordering
functions like newest edge for example
which is essentially a depth
field search then it does matter because
what the newest stage you want to do is
to want it it wants to go as deep
into the causal graph as possible so in
this particular case it goes
one two and then three but then it hits
the limit
of the number of generations which is
three here so it keeps going on as
branches and in the end in this
particular system
it actually produces the same result as
the default inventory function would
do but instead of generations you can
also specify the events count as
i demonstrated previously and this is in
a sense it's a simple way to use it
because now you ask for three events and
this is what you get and then also
you can limit by the number of
uh vertices atoms or expressions
at the final step so that wouldn't work
for multi-way systems but it's
quite useful for single-way systems
because
it it would unlike uh
the number of generations it would
actually terminate as soon as it
it the current state got
more violent storages than requested so
for example here we ask for seven
vertices and we get
seven versus here and the same goes for
edges and you can even combine them
i mean you can combine any of them
including the max events
and so on
and it will terminate as soon as the
earliest of those
is reached
okay so some other properties we can
talk about so the most
straightforward one probably is to
obtaining states
at a particular step or event
of the evolution and the way you can do
it is that you just
give a number to the evolution object
without any property string
or you can also use generation but you
don't have to
because it's assumed by default and
this here for example gives you the
state
at the fourth step of the first fourth
generation
in the evolution another thing you can
do is to
request a state after a particular event
number
so here for example state after seven
cement
again both of these only work for single
way systems because
the ideal state is not very well defined
from outside systems
for local multiverse systems which i
will talk about later
and but you also can come backwards like
when you're doing specific parts of
expressions
so for example here we are requesting a
minus second
event which means it's a
the event which is a previous before the
last one
when we get the state which was
generated after that event
okay so then of course you can plot
these states
with wolfer model plot
in a very straightforward way but you
can also save yourselves
save yourself some typing and just ask
for clause directly
so there is a property called final
state plot which would
give you exactly that and then you can
do states plots list
which gives you plots for each step
along the way and then you can even
specify warfare model plot options as
options for this property
so for example you can say high pressure
rendering those two sub graphs and
you get that here
okay so the next thing you can do is ask
for events
so one of the properties is all events
list
which would give you the
all events so here the first number here
is the index of the rule that was used
and because there's only one rule
here it's always one but it in
in case of multiple groups it could be
something different and then
these numbers here because they are not
hydrated or they're not expressions
themselves
rather the indices of expressions in the
all expressions list
so for example the first event here
takes one two is an input which
corresponds to this
three self loop ternary hyperedges and
then it produces three four five as an
output which are
these ones and
so and one more thing you can do with
events is to visualize them
and here the property is called event
states plots list
and it just gives you plots at a state
after each event
not after not a degeneration but at each
event
and then the red and dotted
hyper edges here highlight where those
events you applied so for example if you
look at
these two states then
the gray dotted
hybridges correspond to hyperedges that
were destroyed
at the next events meaning from this
state and this state
and then the red bold cartridges
correspond to edges that you created
so in in some systems i mean it's it's
more confusing some systems than
others but in some cases it's very
useful to see where
the activity happens in a particular
system
okay so the next thing we can talk about
is causal growth
so expressions events graph
is a kind of causal graph which shows
you not only events but also expressions
and it's in my view it's actually more
useful than the causal graph
and it's again was introduced in the
release yesterday
and for example if you have a system
and i mean i showed some of them before
but
here's another example so if you have a
system which takes two numbers and gives
you some of those numbers
then it just shows exactly how
computation happens
like you take 0 9 you get 9 you get
16 12 28 and so on
so the causal graph is just a compressed
version of this
so if it doesn't have vortices that
correspond to expressions
it only has vertices that correspond to
events and then edges between
these events correspond to causal
connections between events which
correspond to paths
going through expressions in this graph
so for example there are these two
events here correspond to
two events here and there is h between
them because there's pass through
11 here
so there is a property called causal
graph
which just uses the default layout for
the vertices but i recommend you to use
layered causal graph instead which would
put
events at the correct layers
corresponding to their generations
and expression events graph would
automatically do that as well
so one interesting thing about causal
graphs is that they will
let you see quite easily what a possible
evolution orders are for a system and
the way you would get different
evolution orders
is by considering different foliations
of the causal graph and foliation are
just
lines you can draw through it so for
example here
if you draw lines at each
layer in the expressions events graph
they correspond exactly to generations
which are returned by states list in
particular the first element here
is just the initial state
but then the second layer has
11 9 16 and 12 and then this 7 here
correspond to this 7 which is
preserved at this state because it was
never used
at the first step so and the way you can
see it's still the second state because
there is an
edge going through it corresponding to
it
and then you can keep doing it and you
will get all of the states but of course
in different event ordering function
those lines don't have to be straight
and they can can be tilted
which would correspond to different
evolution of them
as a consequence a different reference
frame and
so you can immediately see what kind of
states you can get
in a given system
so one more advantage of using
expressions
events graph over the causal graph
is that it will let you very easily see
where the multi branch happens so for
example let's consider a system
which just a system of a unary
edge moving through a directed graph
so the rule just find this unary edge
and the
directed edge it can go to and it moves
it
to its destination and then if you start
this initial condition like this where
you can see there is a two possible ways
this unit particle can go to
then in a
causal group and if you make a
expression events graph of it
in a multi-way system then it will show
you
that once this unary edge is
at position two
then there are two events that can be
applied to it
one makes it interact with two three and
one makes it interacted
once make it interact is two four
and the way you can see there's multi
branches happening
is because there are two the out degree
of this
expression your x2 is not one
so there are different choices here and
that is something you cannot really see
on the causal graph because
on a causal graph you will just have two
outgoing edges from this event and you
don't know whether it's just this event
created
two edges at the output or if it's
branched like it did here
okay so i can talk more about this
features but i think i will jump to the
local mazdav systems9 i just i'm just
going to briefly mention
what these are so include boundary
events
and it works for basically all
properties and it lets you include
fake initial final events which
is what you can see here and then
meta so there are actually two different
implementations of wolfer mode
one is written wolfram language and it's
more generic and is usually used for
pattern rules and
one is written in c plus plus and it's
typically faster
and method lets you switch between them
and you can also use time constraint
and you can still get partial evolution
objects
when time constraint is reached even if
it didn't finish
evaluating so you can see termination
reason time constraint here
so you have to use evolution objects to
do it if you just
ask for property it wouldn't give you
that
i mean it will just say aborted instead
of result
and then you can specify the order of a
value of events
by using event ordering function
okay but for the multiverse systems
what you want to do is specify the event
selection function
and the reason for it is that
in in the normal evolution which
corresponds to event ordering function
goes to global space like
every expression is only used once
it is never used which corresponds to a
way of selecting
the events means that you cannot select
two events which use the same edge in
that kind of evolution
but by choosing different event
selection functions you can
do that so and i mean you only have two
different cases right now as a global
space like none
but chances are you'll have more pretty
soon
so let's again consider a similar system
as we did previously where you have a
unary
edge going through a directed graph and
in this case
let's make it branch immediately and
then reconverge back
at vertex 4. so in a single revolution
what will happen is that it has to make
a choice either to go to 2
or to go to 3 and it can go to both of
them
because again it cannot reuse this unity
edge at
position one so here's what happens it
picks the earliest edges here
so it goes to two and then it goes to
four
and the edges of expressions one three
and c4 are never used
but if you specify event selection
function goes to none
it's going to both of them so
it will move
to two but it will alternatively move to
three
and you can see the two events coming
out from this
h1 and then it keeps moving to four in
both cases
and now we have two different branches
here
and basically so to
explain again that since
set replace doesn't really care about
states
it can very easily do it because really
all it has is a bucket of
states or it has buckets of expressions
and all it needs to do to produce this
multi-system
is to not delete expressions after
they're used so you can just
reuse them again
but to explain what does it mean for
when selection function goes to none
versus other kind of possible local
multiverse systems
i need to explain what it means for two
expressions to be space like time like a
branch like
so in a single revolution
expressions can be either space like a
timeline and that just depends on
whether there is a causal connection
between them or not
so for instance here
we have a single event that takes
one expression and produces another
expression
and these two expressions are time like
because they're causally connected
so another possibility is to have a
event that produces two
two expressions in which case they're
space-like
because they coexist uh
in they could exist in the same state of
a single revolution
but they're not causally related and
this keeps
preserved i mean after multiple steps as
well so for example here
all of these expressions at the bottom
can coexist with one another in a single
revolution
so they're all space-like with each
other
but in the multiverse system we also
have another type of
relationship between expressions which
is branch-like
and that happens when there are two
different local branches
and there are different edges in them
and those edges
would be branch like separated and the
way you can
see it is that if you go to the common
ancestor
if that common ancestor is an event
that means that those expressions you're
produced
in a consistent way this one another
space like
but if the common ancestor is an
expression
it means that this expression got
marched to two different
events and that in turn means that
it has to be i mean the separation has a
branch like
or in other words there is no
single revolution in which these two
expressions can coexist with one another
and what module system does is that it
matches all groups of expressions
whether they're space like branch cycle
even time like it doesn't care about it
and which is why it's called none
because
there is no selection whatsoever it
chooses all of them
and so for example here these two
expressions one two three and one four
are branch like separated because there
is this expression one two which was
used in both
of these rules but the marginal system
still matches them even though they are
branch like separated
and similarly it can match time like
separated
expressions as well like you see here in
this event
because you can resist two expressions
one two and one to four
are related to one another are causally
but still the this event uses both of
them
as inputs
okay so
so the interesting thing about this
local multi-way module
system is that it actually
allows interference between different
branches
so if you only match space like
separated edges or space like separate
expressions
it means you can only ever get
expressions
that appear on the same uh single
revolution
at the same time but
in a much shorter local military system
that's not the case because for example
here and
this rules are kind of complicated so
you don't i mean you don't have to look
at them so just
look at the output
and here you can see that there is an
event
so this first event is just a normal
event which takes one expression in and
produces two
as expressions
but then here this expression
is an input for two different events and
but there's a merge because it's a
virtual system so it can merge branch
like separated
expressions to each other but then
this event is again has space like
inputs
because these two expressions exist on
different branches
and so in a sense it's kind of like
having some quantum effects happening
here but then
they just influence the
classical state it's kind of like if you
do a quantum experiment somewhere
and then you get a result from this
experiment on your computer
then your computer is perfectly
classical object
but it's influenced by quantum effects
so this is what
i mean it's possible this is how it
looks like
so you have some branching and origin
here which is some kind of quantum
process
and then you get
the event which merges them but
yeah we just use them as inputs and so
on
okay and finally let me explain the
difference between global and local
multivariate systems so
and again let's look at a similar system
as we did
previously uh
with a again unary in this case two
unary
hyperedges moving around the directed
graph
and let's see what the global multiverse
system which is resource function
multiple systems do here
so you can see the global multivariate
system has
states in each vortex
so and it shows them as
entire plots here so in particular
and it enumerates all possible
events that can match the state and
all possible sequences of these events
as well
so like for example here it can move
either one of those particles or the
other one of those particles
uh independently but
because it does it this way there's a
lot of redundancy going on
because for example if you look at these
two highlighted
events they're actually the same event
because they move
this particle on a long branch inwards
and this one does it as well but they
are not
that duplicated here because the states
they start from a different
and that's why you get all this greed
here instead of just
two parts but local multiverse system
wouldn't actually do it because it does
everything locally
and so here we just get this a1
and actually let me copy this
and label the vertices
yeah so as you can see there is an a1
and it keeps moving here
becoming a2 a3 and then m1 and then
b1 also moves inwards becomes b2
and m1 and it
it evolves them independently and then
they only merge at the end
where they well they don't really merge
but they use the same
the same quite pleasure as an input
which is m1 m2
and so in the end you just get two
expressions in two
which is the same as here
but you call them more efficiently so
at the very least the local multi-system
is
an optimization for the cloud multiverse
system
but in addition to that it has this
interesting features because it allows
one to have interactions between
different branches which is an
interesting thing
that needs to be explored more and i
mean since
it's just released yesterday we didn't
really do much
research into what really happens in
those kind of systems but it's
one interesting thing to look at
okay and just a summary so we have again
these are all the
links i showed previously so the
resource functions
on this page then we have a set replace
documentation
and i also written a little bulletin
about
local multiverse systems which
unfortunately done doesn't use
expressions events graph yet because it
didn't exist at the time but
it explains what local multisystems are
in more detail and of course if you have
any questions of any kind but especially
about set replace whether you're trying
to compile it or you
want to modify it or just you just
want to know about what particular
features do
just slack me questions anytime
and they will be happy to answer them
so that's all i had to say
so thank you all for being here
and i'm not sure how it exactly it
should work now but
i think now it's time for questions
so one thing i want to encourage people
is if they
don't want to ask questions directly
here they can post them
in the i guess we can use the physics
um the physics
channel for now and
i i do have a question max so what are
the
uh limitations when using these
functions
on like a regular computer like how many
steps how many evolutions can we
work with without crashing the computer
well so the good thing about it is that
if
your text degrees are small or
alternatively
speaking if the number of matches
is not significantly larger than the
number of events it actually applies
then it has a linear time complexity
this number of events
and you you can go from there so
basically
so they're also memory constrained but
generally you can do
you know at least a couple thousands of
events pretty easily and in some systems
a lot more than that
i assume
so another uh well it's more a comment
than a question so
in in your slides you have uh just
just let me find the correct slide
um so there's one slide you showed
uh for people to install the packet
directly from
from your reaper right because we don't
have the package yet in the
public server i think
right yeah so
i expect some people uh
having issues with backlits and so
maybe we can leave that for let me see
we have the
[Music]
group discussion later today um
he has to show people some of the
backlit uh
functions like i see if i try here on
my machine i think if i check that i
haven't installed your your backlit but
if i
check the version i have is
0.3.15 and i think yours is
26 or something like that yeah
yeah so it will probably be useful for
people to
to see also these backlit uh functions
so in case you know sometimes you have
issues with conflicting versions or
stuff like that so if people are going
to manually install backlits
uh i think we should show these kind of
tools too
well so right so when you install
apocalypse
let's see where is it
yeah so when you install it okay let's
install it again
yeah so when you install the pocket you
just get
version here you can
see it and then well if you are you have
previous version of your try install
newer one
it will just get upgraded automatically
if you're trying to install all the
version then it won't work
by default but you can uninstall it
first and then install it again
and then let's see and then if you use a
script to build install manually it will
automatically delete the previous
version you had
even if it wasn't your one and it will
install the one you
built most recently
so i don't know does it answer the
question
um maybe that's a question for
for the students i'm just i'm trying to
think that so even even from from the
development side we
we have problems sometimes with when
dealing with practice manually so i
expect some
people having these kind of issues so
when you yeah so they are not using here
we are not loading pockets from
development directories here they are
always installed even here
they are installed before they are used
so it's actually pretty straightforward
and once you install the backlit do you
always have to
uh do that get set replace
yeah yeah you need to restart the kernel
uh if you install it in this way you
have to restart
restart your current first and then just
get set replace
i i just wanted to say thank you this
was a really
a great presentation and it was i i
learned a lot
uh more about things uh just from the
regular lectures
um i did have a question yeah thank you
i did have a question um about when you
constructed the foliage
dotted lines um okay
so aviation yeah
so when you want to create a branch like
connected images just based off the
foliation images
is there a different procedure to do
that instead of just creating
dashed lines through graphics when you
want to create those
uh surfaces to visualize well not really
we don't have any automatic way to do it
right now
okay
yeah so i agree it will be definitely
nice to have in particular
like for for a specific evolution we can
construct foliation which would show
where you know how this evolution goes
but we don't have it right now
okay thank you
and also since i think we have the group
discussion
later today um
i guess people can download your slides
and play around with with those and
start
writing other questions so
we can have them we can have the answer
later today
also can you suggest any from from the
technical
uh documents in the physics
uh in the physics website so let me go
there
yeah so um
if you go to get to a technical
introduction
and so
can you suggest any particular uh
section here
uh that illustrates what you show here
so to start also playing around with
this
well most of them use wolfer model in
some way
but well they either use wafer models
they use
multi-way system and you know especially
they
look at other systems and as far as i
know
there's nothing here about the local
multiverse systems
or like what's the best chapter here
what's about section two
um like it's a
background uh reference to to the things
you are showing today
like if people want to play with this
with these uh
tools during the day i'm not sure
there's any particular section here
i mean if you want to see examples
specifically on how to use it you should
just look at readme
but here i mean there are many examples
throughout
but i cannot really point any particular
section
all right so you said your github repo
should be better for that
yeah if you go to just github repository
there is a readme which is
very detailed and has a lot of examples
here
okay
any other questions
oh sorry go ahead i i was gonna say i do
have a
comment i um yesterday download this is
mark
yesterday i um downloaded a document
called
hands-on introduction to the wolfram
physics project
um the title of the
uh of the file is physics tools
i might have changed that though it's a
notebook
um of course it doesn't have the ones
that were published yesterday
uh but that gives you something that you
can actually work through
and play around with i found it very
helpful
yeah that's such a good point um where i
got this
number yeah it's here if you go to
software tools and then introduction to
wall from phoenix project tools
then there are examples here as well
so let's see
and can you put that link on the physics
channel please
thanks
okay there are some questions i'm
getting on slog so
one question what is the difference
between an event and a generation
so event is a single application
of a rule
and generation is as many applications
of the rule
as you can do without making the mobile
up
so only using each cartridge once
is as many events as you can to that's a
generation
and what exactly is the unary age so
a unary edge is just uh show my screen
again
yeah a unary edge is just a edge with a
single vortex in it
so the normal binary edges have two
georgies in it will only have one
logitech that's a universe
okay i think i have another question
my slack
oh let's see
yeah so what does it mean for two edges
to be connected simultaneously in the
causal graph
so that to see what that means you it's
actually useful to look at
expression lens graph so if you haven't
yeah so if you have an event with
multiple outputs or inputs so for
example
you can have an event that takes
one edge in and then to edge out
and we can have another event which
takes two edges in
and one edge out and then if you start
it
from something we do as many events as
we can
and we generate
an expressions lens graph
so you can see there are two pass
through it between these two events
which correspond to two different
expressions
so if we compress it to a causal graph
then they just two edges
uh so it two edges correspond to the
fact that there are
two expressions that you produce by one
events and
then uses inputs by another event but in
the causal graphs there are no vertices
inside of them so
only thing that's left are two edges but
the fact that the two edges here exactly
corresponds to the focus there to pass
here
so are there any other questions
yeah max i just want to say yeah thank
you for the talk i i
me in particular i don't really have any
questions right now because i'm already
fiddling around with your
your slides so that's the probably it's
the same case for other people so
yeah yeah so thank you for providing uh
like a
a slideshow that we can actually like
mess with
sure thank you
i think also um our
room may kick us all out i think we're
supposed to have a group discussion i
don't know if that's supposed to be in
the same room or not we usually have to
like switch between rooms
oh okay let's see
i don't know maybe either aaron or
christian would be would know that
uh i think uh let me check
no i'll get it yeah
yeah it's another in another room
okay the second should we go to another
room what how it works
yeah i think you can you have to know
i have one last question if you have
time
sure uh what can you
i'm very curious about the possibilities
of
exploring hypergraphs um in 3d and
what could you speak to about that
yeah so we don't have offer models 3d
yet
so i was working on it at some time
before but i didn't have time to
actually
finish it there is some prototype on it
in one of those branches which i consume
it
doesn't work that well but what you can
do
in the meantime is that to
kind of to see the structure of a
hypergraph even if you
so you cannot like there is no way right
now to
draw properly the hyper edges
in in 3d but you can always
do the following so you have this hyper
edges
so you can turn them into binary edges
first
by partitioning them
in this way so here i partition
each of them into parts with two
elements each
and one element apart so for example one
two eight becomes
one two and two eight and then we
calculate them
to so that they have single list instead
of lists of lists
and now these are just binary edges
which means
we can say directed edge on them
and i'm applying it to each of those
lists and then you can just do graphs
with d
and we get a 3d graph so it's not
quite as good as well for model plot
because it doesn't tell you
which ones are the hyper edges it it's
essentially
it what it does is the same thing in the
sky pressure underneath the subgraphs do
but it's still pretty useful to see the
chain
you know the general structure of the
craft
that looks uh very nice thank you
all right so once i i had the wrong call
calendar i just updated
uh my calendar and yeah i see we have
the group discussion now so what what we
did with yanchang was
um we we went to that to that zoom room
and you should be a host there
or maybe erin is there and you can say i
should make a breakout rooms
yeah yeah we can make their breakout
rooms um
with the high fidelity space uh
before this this with jonathan's lecture
um but probably here using the
if you are going to share the screen
soon
will be better so uh i suggest we move
to that
uh zoom session so you can create a
breakout rooms
and in the in the breakout rooms
channel in slack um i can create a
thread for
each room and people can post their
questions there
okay so how many people per room
do you think would make sense
how do you assign people to the breakout
group how many people per room
how many people uh i don't know i think
it depends on
how many people we have here
and i think so i can make rooms of
different sizes
i believe so yes
well okay that's good so
uh yeah i think we should just move
there and and organize the rooms
in that simulation
wait in a different zone session yeah
yeah just go to
the calendar and okay okay
and you should get the let me see
um yeah group discussions
physics tools one and
and there's a okay yeah there is
this you just have to click the join
live meeting sure and yeah
directed to the session okay so i'll see
okay